[موسيقى]
شراك بحث عن دعم الولايات المتحده في وقت
كنا في كانت علاقاتنا سيئه مع واشنطن بسبب
حرب العراق كما اشرت اليه قبل قليل اذا
كنا نحتاج لموقف مجتمع الدولي موحد ازاعه
مشروع مشترك كنا نريد على نريد قرار من
مجلس الامن
لمطالبه من انسحاب القوات السوريه من
لبنان لمنحي لبنان متنفس لمواصله التنميه
والاستقرار وتجنب التدخل الاجنبي
تعلمين كيف
حدث ذلك فتم اغتيال رفيق الحريري وبعد ذلك
لم تنسحب القوات السوريه الا بعد عام من
ذلك وهذه هي كانت النتيجه السياسه التي
انتهجت في ذلك الوقت
[موسيقى]
لا استطيع ان اقول انني اتهم نظام السوري
بذلك ففي ذلك الوقت كما تعلمين جرت جرى
تحقيق مثبه لجنه تحق تحقيق على الارض وتم
طبعا استجواب شهود وتم توقيف بعض الاشخاص
كل ذلك جرى في سياق بالغ صعوبه
والتعقيد في لبنان وفي المنطقه ايضا كان
هناك عدد من الوقائع جعلتنا نتساءل ولكن
لم يعد لنا ولا يمكن ان نقول له شخصيا
لا يمكن نقول ان سوريا هي المسؤوله كان
هناك عوامل تجعلنا نعتقد بان رفيق الحريري
كان يزعج وان اختفاءه كان يخدم مصالح
البعض لا استطيع ان اضيف اكثر من ذلك
[موسيقى]